una ciudad de luto una vez más mientras
se encendían velas y se derramaban
lágrimas fuera de nosotros de amenizar
las oraciones sonaron en tributo a las
tres personas asesinadas aquí el jueves
por su fe entre las víctimas bajo lo que
era el sacristán de la basílica la
garganta del hombre de 55 años fue
cortada momentos después de que abriera
las puertas de la iglesia el jueves por
la mañana cuando la gente de niza se
enteró del ataque muchos corrieron a
nuestro drama completamente aturdidos
por las noticias sólo podían mirar con
desesperación
lo que acabamos de ver en la televisión
que el sacristán de la iglesia fue
asesinado es un shock
y lo veía caminando todo el tiempo
encendiendo velas y ahora escucho que ya
no está
[Música]
una mujer de 60 años y otra de 44
también fueron asesinadas niza no es
ajena a asesinatos como estos la
ofensiva del jueves fue la tercera de
este tipo en tan solo cinco años en 2015
un terrorista apuñaló a tres soldados en
una patrulla un año más tarde en junio
de 2016 86 personas fueron asesinadas en
el famoso comodities doble el ataque
mortal de este jueves ha reabierto
viejas heridas
es horrible me casé aquí estoy aquí al
menos tres veces a la semana y una vez
más nos han golpeado directamente en el
corazón
[Música]
estoy harto un lugar sagrado además dos
horas después del mortal ataque del
jueves
muchos se congregaron fuera de la
catedral de la ciudad mientras misa
trata de aceptar otro acto de terrorismo
que ha sacudido su ciudad